je répéterai pas ce soir on fait le tour
de l'usiné on revient
qui ne courir
si tu gagnes tu gagnes mais si tu perds
regardez
ghoga
m
je vais faire la course
qu'est-ce que tu conduis un carrosse
avec des licornes
qui contrôle tôt
moi sergent johnson j'ai apporté
quelques dossiers c'est le moment de
faire de la paperasse tu crois c'était
une sirène tôt ça veut dire qu'il est
impliqué tout le monde à terre je vois
je t'ai eue certeau ya personne en fait
bon d'accord si on veut réussir ce casse
va falloir renforcer l'équipe pour
commencer une plaque de service qu anne
asiat magnifique mannequin qui de se
lancer l'ancien où tu fais ce à quoi tu
le décris et comme par magie
ils sont là mais qu'est ce qu'ils
foutent chef je suis pas inquiet
il a
oh
merci des très bons mouvements n'a
besoin que d'un seul conducteur vous
allez passer une audition canton toi de
me suivre à savoir pourquoi tu te barres